Hello everyone, I hope that you are
good. What's going on with Bitcoin?
Well, to be honest, not much, okay?
Because we are still in this kind of
sideways and boring move.
I know much is really going on, and
that's why I didn't post any YouTube
videos this week because I'm basically
sticking to my Bitcoin Sunday updates.
You can go to Twitter and check it out
if you want. But we want to talk about
that also in a minute, okay?
I wanted to post this video today
because I want to remind you that today
we might see some more volatility in the
charts because at 6:00 p.m. UTC time,
that's in pretty much 3 hours and a half
from here,
they are going to release the FOMC
minutes.
Now, the FOMC minutes, don't get them
confused with a different FOMC meeting
cuz it's not the same.
It's today they are not going to decide
whether to increase, pause, or cut
interest rates.
That's not what it's about today.
The FOMC minutes are essentially the
notes that the Fed members took in the
previous FOMC meeting, so they can give
us an idea of what the Fed members
expect for the economy in the following
months, their ideas, their concerns,
and it can give us some kind of an idea.
You might remember that a few months ago
in the FOMC minutes, they talked about a
recession. They mentioned recession.
It's true that they mentioned a mild
recession.
But the chart reacted to that report,
right? Now, it's true that they're
talking now that there is not going to
be a recession anymore, but
I'm not sure, guys. I don't know what
you guys think, but to me, this reminds
me of 2008. They did exactly the same
thing, and then you know what happened
in 2008, right?
So, I don't know, guys.
But anyway, let's see what they say
today.
Uh don't expect uh again in a new
interest rate decision cuz it's not
going to happen today.
Uh it's only notes of the previous FOMC
meeting, but it still is quite valuable
because it can give you some kind of an
idea of what they are talking about,
what they expect, what they discuss,
etc.
Now, I want you to think how the FOMC
minutes can impact the Bitcoin chart,
the Bitcoin price action, okay?
And basically you have to think that the
information that comes out
in that report
is important in the chart. Because if
the minutes is favorable
for the DXY, for the US dollar, then
Bitcoin's going to go down. Now, you
have to think what can they possibly say
to pump the dollar and dump Bitcoin in
that context? Well,
for the minutes to be favorable for the
US dollar, they, for example, have to
mention that yeah, it's likely that we
see new interest rates hikes,
you know, things like these. Then,
if that happens, the dollar index should
pump, Bitcoin should dump.
Okay? And again, in the opposite
direction, if they change their mind now
and they mention rate cuts,
uh by the way, I don't think this is
going to happen at all, but if they
mention rate cuts, the possibility of
rate cuts, then I can tell you the DXY's
going to go down and Bitcoin is going to
go up.
All right? So, this is what I mean. At
the moment, in this bear market where we
have, you know, inflation, we also have
a strong labor market, we also have the
recession around the corner,
the markets are very, very data
dependent, okay? And you don't know what
if they're going to say in the minutes.
Cuz they could say either of those
things. Or maybe they say nothing.
All right? We don't know. So, that's
what I mean. Be careful. Try to go flat
into the FOMC minutes. Again, I know I
always tell you go flat into FOMC and go
flat into CPI and also into non-farm
payrolls because those three things
can go into any direction and you have
no information about that in advance.
So, that would be gambling. Okay, so be
very careful today at 6:00 p.m. UTC
time. Now, what do I think Bitcoin might
do in the following days and weeks?
Well, we've been talking in the Sunday
update about the idea
of a false move right at the start of
the week. That's the short-term target
that was 29,640.
Okay? They hit it somewhere around here.
All right? Why was I talking about this
target? Well, basically because there
was an open interest gap over there.
Okay?
Uh in the course, I always talk about
the open interest gap. I explain what it
is. In Twitter, I I also mention it. But
basically, you have to consider that
open interest gaps are imbalances in the
chart. They're imbalances in the order
book. So, price tends to fill them.
Okay? Then you can see a reversal. Not
necessarily, but usually so that you see
a reversal there. But they act as
magnetic zones. So, that's why I was
thinking in that, you know, if there is
an open interest gap so close from the
current price, it only takes a quick
spike up to fill it.
You understand that. So, that's what I
was talking, the idea that we might see
a spike up at the start of the week,
fill the open interest gap, and then
what happened after is going to decide
where Bitcoin goes. And what I was
mentioning is if we can hit 29,640
and hold above the range lows, that's
this
white line over here.
Okay?
If we could hold above it,
then yes, there was going to be
a a possibility for Bitcoin to continue
going higher and hit the mid-range,
30,500.
All right? Now, if you notice,
they hit 29,640,
they fill the open interest gap, and
then they dump price below the range
lows, and also
below the daily 50 MA.
Okay? That's the daily 50 MA in your
chart now.
So, right now you are below two main
resistances.
Which to me means that I cannot really
favor 30,500 from here. So, I'm
leaning towards the possibility of going
to this potential support over here.
This potential support comes out from
here. From this idea, right? One hit
there, two hits there. That's was
resistance, but we never got to test it
at that support. Okay? So, that's what I
mean. That's a potential support that is
not confirmed because price might just,
you know,
rip to do the downside from here.
Okay?
That's right now what I'm favoring the
most. It's a drop there.
But,
it's true that this has happened many
times before. Check this out.
You have here this pump
and this pump. And notice how, for
example, in this pump price came lower.
Again, below the range lows and below
the 50 EMA in the daily time frame. And
then it just consolidates long, another
push, more consolidation. So,
it's not clear and it's not definite
that Bitcoin is going to doom from here
straight away to 28,300.
All right? Also,
if you notice here,
you have this
I don't want to call it a support. Okay?
I want to talk about what happened here.
In my opinion, what is going on here is
that they are setting price down
just to you know, build longs over here,
okay? There you go. A push up, another
push up, another one, another one. And
when this happens, this means that they
are building
their longs. Also, notice how aggressive
these moves are.
To the upside, the reversal, but also to
the downside. Check this out. Large red
candle, large red candle, large red
candle. Okay? And when that happens,
then you usually see a pump. So, the
question is, is this the pump?
Is that the pump that we were looking
for? And now it's finished and now price
is going to go down all the way here or
is a possibility that
they are still developing that move.
Which means
that you might see here again
more reversals happening inside this box
and then you can see the real reversal
to the mid-range.
That's also an idea. That's why if you
want to favor lower prices
you don't want to see more reversals,
more more bounces happening inside this
box because that could tell you that in
the midterm they're actually building
longs.
It's not clear, okay? I don't know if
this was the pump
or if they are going to, you know
bring price again
to this box to continue building longs
and then make a higher move.
It's not clear at the moment. If I had
to choose
by looking at the chart, this is a very
bold guess because it's based on
nothing.
All right, but hang on. Let me get back
to this. All right. But if I had to
choose
because this pump
over here
is breaking the previous high
okay?
I think that that was it.
In my opinion, I think that that was it.
So, I think that this idea
of coming back down all the way to
28,300
it's more likely.
All right, but again
for that
first of all is is not confirmed at all
because you might still see more bounces
here and if we see that
then I'm going to start to dismiss this
idea. All right, but by looking at the
chart I think that what they were
preparing
in this zone it was basically
this pump over here.
All right, and I think that now we might
see Bitcoin going lower
to 28,300. Now, don't know if this is
going to happen
this week or the next week. Bitcoin is
at the moment
in in a sideways move. It's quite
boring.
All right?
But,
that's the thing that you have to keep
an eye on. And also, of course, in the
FOMC minutes today because that could be
a catalyst to bring price down or up
either direction in a very aggressive
move. I don't think that the Fed's
members know that they have to be
cautious and conservative with what they
say because I think that they know that
inflation
is going to be a problem in the second
half of the year.
I also posted that I wrote about this on
Twitter. But, basically, the idea is
that the year-over-year inflation CPI
comes regarding the previous 12 months.
And if you notice,
June, July of last year is when CPI was
coming down very sharply. From today's
onwards, from this month's onwards,
all the CPI data
it's fighting against the previous 12
months when it was quite positive. So,
there isn't that much room to be
positive, okay? Because that was 12
months ago, that was the peak of CPI.
Then it came down very aggressively.
And now we're fighting against those
numbers. So, if you want to see
inflation coming down,
it's going to be regarding the previous
12 12 months.
So, that's going to be a problem for the
Fed. And they know it. So, I don't think
that they're going to talk about
interest rate cuts. I think they're
still going to be
They're going to say, "We're
data-dependent.
Inflation is still a problem. It hasn't
reached our target of 2%. The labor
market is still quite strong. So, there
might be new interest rate hikes." Okay?
I think that's more likely to happen,
and that could bring Bitcoin a bit
lower.
All right? So, that's what you have to
think, guys. Now, if you're going to
high block capital,
we're going to get surprised, I think.
Why in high block capital 7-day time
frame?
Um
This is the surprise. Check this out.
This looks like the 12-hour time frame.
It's
full of liquidity everywhere you look.
Check this out. Well, right now you have
28,150,
very close from the current price.
I think it's very, very likely that we
hit this zone today because we are only
a couple hundred dollars away. So, even
before the FOMC minutes or if price
consolidates here, then with the FOMC
minutes they're going to take this zone.
That's what I think. 28,150.
But, if you check to the downside, then
you also have here 28,300.
That's the zone that we were talking
about. All right?
And to the upside,
you also have
29,150.
Oh, I messed it up. Sorry.
And I think it was
30,500.
Well, 30,450, okay?
That's the mid-range.
So, this is what I'm talking about. It's
There is so much liquidity everywhere
that we cannot favor a direction.
Okay?
That's what you have to be really
careful, okay? Because yes, if we can
see, you know, if you remove
two or three bars from here,
then we can
we can be more confident about what the
direction for Bitcoin could be.
All right? But, having, you know, two
yellow bars to the upside, two yellow
bars to the downside is not clear at
all. But, again,
I think it's more likely that we come at
least today to 28,150,
and either this week or next week, I
would like to see 28,350. But, again,
we'll see.
So, be careful, guys. I don't know if
this week I'm going to be able to post
any more videos because I got a flight
for my brother to come and visit me here
in Georgia.
Uh so he can have some some holidays and
we can spend some time together. So, I
don't know, okay? He's going to be here
for almost a a week.
Um I want to spend time with him, okay?
So, again, uh I'm not sure if I'm going
to be able to post any videos, but I'm
going to of course stay active on
Twitter and in Telegram, Discord. So, if
anything you need,
you can probably find me more in Twitter
this week.
All right, guys. So, thank you so much
for watching
and I'll see you soon.